joining me now is Miranda Divine New
York Post columnist and a Fox News
contributor Miranda why would Hunter
Biden who's at Rosemont Seneca need to
talk to his dad about a White House
position and recommend someone to put
there
hi Kaylee look it's because uh Hunter
Biden played a role as kind of a
consigliere to his father when he was
vice president people used to come to
Hunter cap in hand and ask for favors
for from Joe whether it be a plush White
House job in a senior position or
whether it was a judgeship whether it
was
recommendations for their children to
get into some Posh school
um Hunter Biden was kind of the
gatekeeper to his father and he used
that access to benefit himself in a
number of ways including enriching
himself but in this case you're just
seeing a classic father-son quid pro quo
which Joe Biden
enables that access using these
pseudonyms that you just mentioned these
Alias emails I think there are about
five the
the National Archives has said that
they've got over 5 000 emails from just
three of those aliases you know if you
work it out it's he Joe Biden was
sending during his vice presidency at
least two of these
um or using these Alias emails to send
emails at least twice a day and why you
know that's the question he was
conducting official business using these
Alias emails the natural suspicion is
that he wanted to hide something and
it's really not up to the National
Archives to keep that secret from the
American people
Miranda and and that is the key question
I have so the archives has 5 000 of
these emails they were requested by a
legal organization in June of 2022. it
is now August of 2023 so why does it
take more than a year to turn over these
emails
look great question and I Senators
Johnson and Grassley actually asked for
these emails back in 2021
um there's just been complete
stonewalling but of course with the
impeachment inquiry looming uh probably
next month of Joe Biden these emails
have come into Focus again and they're
newly important I think they were
overlooked at the time and people now
realize in the with all the other
information that's come out if they're
part of the jigsaw puzzle that show that
something nefarious was being conducted
by Joe Biden as vice president
yeah and of course the White House they
say nothing to see here well I want
Comer to get the emails and then the
people can decide Miranda thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else